rtl est elle définitivement devenu lé
raymond poulidor des audiences alors je
le dis et je le répète rtl je les aime
j'aime rtl et c'est grâce à eux si j'ai
pu faire cette petite carrière voilà que
j'ai peine aujourd'hui parce que c est
elle qui m'a fait confiance en premier
et je vous le dis quand je vois rtl
deuxième radio de france
oui ça fait mal oui ça me fait mal ça me
fait mal ça me hérisse le poil
oui les chéris c'est très dur rtl est
devancé par france inter sur tous les
indicateurs france inter et première
radio de france
une radio que je n'ai jamais écouté de
ma vie et pourtant ils sont connus comme
quoi je ne sais pas représentés savez m
radio voilà puisque c'est la première
radio en durée d'écouté musicale c'est
incroyable et c'est vrai merci et
j'écoute bien sur skyrock avec mon
difool d'amour qui est le seul à car ce
n'est encore bravo mon difool cyr et rfm
jamais la safer slr fm une radio
bien sûr qu'ils existent regardez petit
récap et isabelle on va t'elle dois
retenir quelque chose qui ont débarqué
ce matin et le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes pour tout le monde
je suis d'accord avec vous sur un an le
média radio dans sa globalité a perdu
près de 2 millions d'auditeurs en
moyenne une baisse qui ne se répercute
pas de la même manière sur toutes les
stations
mais tout va bien en tête de course on
retrouve bien entendu les radios
généralistes est la grande gagnante de
cette vague a du rouge dans son logo et
s'appelle la meilleure airtel non is as
et france inter
uniway droits télés radios publiques qui
remporte ce match des audiences et
s'impose avec 14 buts 7 % de part
d'audience comme leader incontestable
c'était un moment de grâce à la carte et
elle se retrouve quant à elle en seconde
position du classement et perd presque
un point sur un an en audience cumulée
on s'est dit qu'on avait touché le fond
mais en fait non on retrouve ensuite
france bleu rmc est en queue de peloton
europe 1 qu' avec une part d'audience de
3 vers 1h pourtant continue sa
douloureuse chute en atteint les limites
du ridicule
du côté des musicales malgré une lourde
baisse nrj reste leader avec 5 2 6%
suivis par skyrock et rock assez bonne
idée si rtl reste une radio qui se porte
bien avec ces derniers sondages elle
semble avoir perdu pour de bon sa place
historique de première radio de france
ça marche moins bien qu'avant alors rtl
était définitivement deux nuls raymond
poulidor des audiences pour parler
sérieusement laurent ruquier cartonne
toujours là prêt lundi loin devant en
tête julien courbet ou aux amis aussi
qui cartonne voilà que le dis
franchement julien cart n ya rien à dire
voilà julien et laurent cartonne voilà
après france apparaît certes elle
s'arrête des mouches ils sont
malheureuses moi je dis malheureusement
parce que je peux qu'rtl de redevienne
première à d'autres en sont
malheureusement deuxième et je voudrais
dire europe 1 vous allez voir ça va
remonter parce que j'aime aussi cette
radio europe 1 a donné ma chance et qui
sont les gens formidables là bas ils
entendent vraiment et ça va finir par
remonter vous savez ah mais vous dire
c'est comme dans un jeu tu es un truc
dans l'eau un moment
tu vas voir que ça et je serai toujours
derrière europe 1 parce que c'est des
gens formidables et je peux vous dire
ils m'ont souvent souvent idée donc
voilà bravo
il s'appelle est ce que vous pouvez dire
quelque chose qu'on pouvait avouer que
rtl et deuxième radio de france et vous
plaît il faut le dire à mon à lézat non
mais et il nous faut ou non c'est juste
en les laissant pleurer mais oui c'est
comme si c'est des chiffres pas ici la
vérité pantalons plus tôt non je suis
quand même registre a menacé nicolas de
tavernost c'est le président rtl
et ici nous le patron nicolas pianet
robert mais le président de tous
totalement confiant oui mais est-ce que
vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes mais oui
parce que là non mais vous allez ou bien
faut le dire à être confiant tout ce
dont vous êtes combien elle sait que la
première radio france la première à
double sens sur beaucoup de sueur
beaucoup à l'équipe
oui c'est faire plus sinon les aider
giuly est la première scène de france et
ça m'écorche le culte de dire c'était
vrai nous on a gagné dans laissez vous
tenter 38 mille auditeurs encore à vous
venez de le dire balala quelle est la
première de mal je vais faire comme
bernard et motivés n'y a pas de rayonner
la première à 2 puis alors en ce moment
oui ça ne fait pas plaisir et je pense
que ça ne s'est pas avéré c'est le dira
t'on bêtement balawi en ce moment en
france un verre actualité oblige et
première à 12 mois
[Applaudissements]
caméra notre france et je suis pas
comment ou non plus les 16 chefs
oui puisque nagui toros moi j'écoute
walaja cnac yaghi je compte en ligne et
antoine de caunes ce que j'arrive là
reste savane de caunes et sonia
devillers province voient là le climat
ça fait un truc c'est que et ça je
trouve ça moche c'est qu'alors qu'on a
une info sur le virus absolument
remarquable les gens y pensent que le
service public mais françois clerc le
pour sa rue et france info est
totalement à tort je dis pas qu'ils font
du mauvais boulot je dis qu'ils font pas
un boulot meilleurs que nous et que ça
pour le coup les gens les gens ne le
voient - ah oui oui madame
il ya plein de trucs à dire sur ces
chiffres la première banque allemande
déclaratif ça fonctionne pas c'est
certain mais c'est trop tard alors que
moi je pense que les les chaînes
musicales c'est mort ça va être très dur
je pense que ça les jeunes n'écoutent
plus la radio nous on écoutait la radio
de cbc sur l'armagnac zemor à paris s'en
sort il ya des fouilles qui s'en sort
bien
well et globalement je sais ce que j'ai
à nous avions les ados aujourd'hui
manger j'ai trois ados à la maison il
n'y a aucun qui écoutent la radio c'est
très très rare dans une consommation
quand même absolument différente et
ensuite les gens vieillissent et les
gens écoutent de moins en moins la radio
ça j'en suis sûr aussi et donc voilà je
pense que c'est très compliqué pour la
radio il va falloir se réinventer mais
iliad ayant concis clair encore des
choses à faire merci s'il vous plaît si
vous constatez des cantons s'échangeant
texans ont dit que la radio va mal les
musicales vont mal après il faut pas
oublier aussi qu'il ya un contexte de
comines les gens font beaucoup de
télétravail exact mais est ce que toi
aussi tu te dis que tu exactement alors
ce que dit raymond et je le dis au
télétravail dans les chiffres a dit en
ce moment ils sont extrêmement biaisé et
puis la radio on écoute le plus souvent
dans la voie inverse non seulement quand
on est ou en télétravail ou qu'on est en
couvre feu on écoute beaucoup moins la
radio donc forcément c'est plus
compliqué surtout pour les radios
musicales qui sont des radios et s'il
n'ya plus jeune donc les jeunes
eh ben il écoute mon la radio parce
qu'ils sont chez 2 et les plus âgés à la
limite il écoute aussi souvent la radio
chez eux les fléchages et écoute encore
la radio à la maison donc ce qui est un
petit peu gênant exif c'est tout ce qui
se passe actuellement parce qu'ils sont
un petit peu les essais vrai qu'énergie
dévisse totalement et
vive remontée quand on aura repris une
activité normale
oui et oui tu rassembles info un moment
donné et vous qu'est médias des enquêtes
vous trouvez pas ça bizarre que quand
même france inter était aussi la
première radio de france
quand il ya eu trois mois de grève vous
trouvez çà bizare chirac sait très bien
ce qu'il ya trois mois c'est vrai et 35
heures était première de trois sa série
incroyable et est ce qu'il ya un
problème alors je vais vous expliquer
comment ça se passe ce sont les
audiences radio c'est très simple cas il
peut donc il ya plusieurs sites sont
dédiés aux audiences radio ou sont des
gens qui sont dans une salle et qu'ils
ont un téléphone et qui vont appeler des
personnes au halal sélectionné voilà où
on en voit là pour leur dire qu'est-ce
que vous avez écouté alors oui bonjour
qu'est ce que vous avez écouté hier
entre 8h et 10h
bah je sais pas moi rtl à montbert tl
dakola après vous avez écouté quoi entre
10h à 12h et là le mec qui l'aï regardé
je sais pas mais j'ai vu le ciel skype
non mais donc voilà donc c'est ça et je
peux vous dire ce que ça à mon avis
c'est un bordel né chez lui alors je
vais demander à nicolas pernikoff
nicolas pernikoff qui était un des gros
taulier d'énergie aussi on a tendance à
l'oublier
nicolas pernikoff des années et des
années chez nrj la panthère c'était lui
dans l'inventaire qui colle à perdre en
fait ils appellent les gens et leur
demandent ce que vous écoutiez rivières
comme radio de 5 heures à 24 heures
ce qui est compliqué parce que à sigean
passait dans la rue puisque à l'époque
nous et nrj ont été très présent
puisqu'on était la radio des concerts
donc vous voyez vous étiez exposés à des
logos ou énergie partagée par tous donc
forcément dès qu'il y avait ce genre d'
enquête les gens ils répondaient énergie
si c'est ce que vous voyez énergie
partout maintenant il ya deux choses
importantes effectivement s'excuser dia
le nombre de visiteurs en moins en un an
qui est colossal
ce sont deux millions d'auditeurs en
moins qu on est quasiment à l'an 2000
c'est à dire au niveau de l'an 2000
après il ya autre chose c'est
qu'effectivement on est dans une
population ce que vous disiez géraldine
vieillissante et aujourd'hui les moins
de 25 ans je suis désolé ils sont sur
les plateformes aviation le streaming de
gaza mais ils sont pas de casse sont pas
là c'est même pire c'est d'arriver
france inter était un des premiers à
l'époque
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas mathieu
gallet il a été un des premiers à créer
cette plate forme de postulat des 400
par ailleurs c'est exactement
il ya quand même beaucoup de jeunes
aujourd'hui il ya cette nouvelle
génération qui écoute des podcasts dans
les métros dans les rer quand ils
voyagent et ça c'est ils ont été les
premiers là dessus maintenant est ce que
la radio musicale va remonter je me pose
des questions pour la musicale c'est
très dur parce que ce qui vient dire
c'est très juste il ya des podcasts il
faut pas oublier que maintenant les
voitures sont plus en plus connectés et
à ta playlist du jeu on a tous mais tous
nos playlists nos voitures avant en
écoutant on attendait trois heures sans
avoir michael jackson michael jackson
clé c'est vrai qu'à l'époque oui ce gala
il attendait c'est à dire que c'est vrai
écoutez pas ma peine et contrats jamais
maintenant ce rigoler moi j'attends plus
kenji bien entendu j'ai eu les ici ou
sur spotify et vas-y que riche en
échange d'un abandon il chantait joe
weithman partiellement banquette moi y'a
un truc qui m'exaspère un peu les
audiences radio c'est que quand on lis
les communiqués des stations on a appris
tout le monde a gagné tout qui manquent
de netteté chez toutes les radios disons
des premières radios sur terre
indicateurs et c'est très dur pour les
gens de s'y retrouver et sur les
méthodes de mesure je suis d'accord et
nicolas c'est archaïque et c'est très
dur parce que vous savez que c'est ça
qui régit toute l'économie des radio
tout info sont les sur les honneurs
c'est que médiamétrie est en train de
mettre en place un système hors sol
c'est-à-dire d'équiper les ceintures les
montrer tout pour testez vous pour faire
comme pour la télé j'ai le font éclater
les doter je suis un père s'il a écouté
en tout cas la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
que rtl2 est vrai que jamais et ça ça
fait mal au cul cul ça fait mal au cul
financièrement force ça fait mal au cul